[Music]
just in time for christmas the trailer
for the disney plus marvel series loki
has finally arrived
hold on to your helmet horns and melt
into the multiverse as we break down
some of the small details you might have
missed
after a recap of loki stealing the
tesseract in avengers end game
and a scene of him waking up in a desert
we see the mischievous antihero on an
elevator with a lot of weird buttons
descending a huge building
we then see multiple shots inside this
building which seems to be some kind of
cosmic governmental headquarters
filled with strange statues signs and
vaguely threatening looking people
this would appear to be the headquarters
of the tva and we aren't talking about
the tennessee valley authority
in this case tva stands for the time
variants authority
an organization that first appeared in
1986's thor
issue 372. they've popped up a few times
in the intervening years
and their mission is to maintain the
integrity of the timeline
and prosecute those who threaten to
screw with it they've tangled with time
time-traveling villains like kang the
conqueror
who has himself been rumored to be
coming to the mcu soon
they're basically a bureaucratic force
of time police in the authority's first
appearance
one of the tva's agents was chasing an
immortal demonic bad guy named zaniak
back through time to stop him from
causing massive chaos in the future
could zaniac have something to do with
the weird stained glass demon we see
later in the trailer
or could that be some other devilish
marvel villain like mephisto
standing in the elevator next to loki is
none other than owen wilson
playing a mysterious character whose
name is never mentioned
but if you hit the closed caption button
it reveals his character name without
any guesswork mobius and mobius
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say
you know time passes differently here in
the tva it's a safe bet that most fans
of comics both old and new
have probably never heard of this
obscure character who first appeared in
fantastic four
issue 353 in 1991. mr mobius is in
charge of prosecuting the fantastic four
for their time travelling shenanigans
that tracks with what we see in the
trailer there's a high-tech looking film
strip
that seems to be evident against loki
then mobius sitting at a table with loki
who's clearly being held prisoner by the
tva
mr mobia seems to be taking loki to task
for his crimes against time
and possibly putting him to work to set
some things right
three very ominous looking figures loom
large in the offices of the tva
first they show up as three giant heads
hanging behind gugu on batara
who's playing an as yet unnamed
character we see them again as three
gigantic statues
who are they as ever the pages of marvel
comics hold the most probable answer
these are most likely the time keepers
characters whose origins are tied to the
time variance authority
their story is very very complicated and
involves multiple timelines in perfect
past versions of themselves called the
time twisters and a guy named
zarko the tomorrow man whether we'll see
or hear more of them or just see the
statues in the background isn't known at
this point
in a blink and you'll miss it moment a
group of tva agents
along with loki march into a big box
store called roxcut
that name bears a striking similarity to
one of the many fictional corporations
that have shown up in marvel comics over
the years
roxanne energy corporation if you've
played through 2020 spider-man miles
morales video game
you're already familiar with roxanne and
his nefarious corporate misdeeds roxanne
has been in the mcu from the start
with their logo appearing on a building
during the climactic fight in iron man
the president even says the name in iron
man 3.
this is the roxanne norco roxanne has
also been a key part of several
mcu tv shows and the logo is on a gas
pump in the marvel one shot short film
a funny thing happened on the way to
thor's hammer it's not entirely clear
what larger role roxcart might even play
in the overall show
but considering how evil the corporation
tends to be in the comics and
games don't be surprised if we hear from
this evil conglomerate throughout loki
and beyond the trailer ends with a
classic loki smile and quip
flanked by what appears to be a group of
battle-worn warriors from various
historical periods the trickster god
opens his arms smiles and says
come on what did you expect
loki's not so merry band of fighters
that immediately turned their weapons on
him a telling detail is that loki and a
few of the warriors behind him
are wearing red white and blue buttons
that say loki for president
the buttons appear to be a call back to
the 2016 comic book series voter loki
which finds the norse guard launching a
controversial campaign for president of
the united states
vote loki is a satire of the actual 2016
u.s presidential election and features
fictional ex-daily bugle reporter
lisa contreras working to expose his web
of lies
so does loki actually change history in
the show there's some evidence at one
point we see loki inside a massive plane
except he really doesn't look like loki
he gives the flight attendant a wink
grabs a bag from her then jumps out of
the plane cash fluttering in the wind
behind him as he appears to zap to
asgard via the bifrost
this seems to be the god of mischief
masquerading as dan db cooper
the pseudonym of a still unidentified
man who hijacked a seattle-bound plane
on november 24 1971 the man who wore
black sunglasses a black suit and a
black tie
just like loki in the trailer told a
flight attendant that he had a bomb
then managed to extort nearly 1.3
million dollars in ransom
he parachuted out of the plane and was
never seen again the as yet and fruitful
investigations of db cooper have
attracted the attention of millions
around the world
apparently including the folks at disney
and marvel loki is said to follow the
titular character throughout time
and passing himself off as or actually
being the subject of one of the most
bizarre unsolved mysteries in history
is very low-key check out one of our
newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the mcu
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you